honestly i think you're basically my
fairy godmother
and i think it's a testament to my life
that anything is possible
yes it is anything is possible i'm so
glad that you you think that
most people probably recognize you from
your time
on ln you are such a light whenever i
see you on that show
thank you has she ever given you any
great advice that you carry with you
today
you know what i would honestly say that
the advice is actually just being in her
presence and watching her work
you know i think i i have a great
blessing to be able to sit at you know
the number one talk show and to be able
to sit there and watch
how it operates and how it runs and how
she carries herself
and how she approaches the content and
how she can get a joke across
or how the audience feels about her i
think that's one of the most powerful
things about our show
on ellen or outside of ellen you have
had the opportunity to really
meet and work alongside like some
huge people in the entertainment
industry
is there someone that you met that you
still just get
butterflies thinking about mariah carey
mariah carey
you're great at hugs am i that was
wonderful i have never worked with a
celebrity ever so collaborative i
remember us
doing a shot and then they'd be like
okay mariah does that work for you be
like oh well
does that work for caitlyn if it works
for him and i'm like baby you're mariah
carey are you kidding me you don't need
to ask me for permission honey i'm just
grateful to be here you know
and i that moment would live with me
forever it just
really warmed my heart i know that you
posted on your social media in the
summer that you were taking a break from
things
how are you feeling now i feel as though
the content that i have been making and
the things
that i've been working on the special
projects that i've done are truly
what i am you know i think when
especially like we're going to talk
about the christmas album like
singing is something that i've always
done my entire life and so during that
time that i took off
i started to tap back into passions that
i always had
so what i did really during that time is
found a way to honor my
inner child
a christmas album for a debut album
usually isn't the norm well i thought
about my life
and i thought about how every year no
matter what has been going on in that
year or how i felt that entire year
as soon as i get to christmas time in
the holidays
my spirit is just rejuvenated i feel joy
i feel
hopeful there is a feeling that i feel
during that time and i
knew what this year had been for so many
people
and i said i want to be able to take
that same joy that i feel around the
holidays
and give it back to people and when i
wrote a song on my album
uh christmas lives within you i think
when you listen to it it gives very
mariah
you know i wrote it from the heart and
the reason why i wrote that song is
because i thought about all
the queer children around the world and
families that do not get to go home for
the holidays and so i wanted to be
sure that i had a song that said it
doesn't matter if you don't have a tree
if you don't have lice if you don't have
gifts under the tree
that's not what christmas means that's
not what it's supposed to
feel like you know and regardless of
what anybody says
christmas still lives within you well
you also
were able to get two incredible people
on the album who
i love mj and alex was it just like
right away were they like yes i'll do it
let's do it is that how it happened oh
absolutely i just sent them a text and
what is so funny is that alex was in
vancouver
so we had to get studio space for alex
in vancouver
and then we had uh mj who was in new
york proposed so then we had to get her
studio time in new york
but they were just so gracious and
willing to participate in the apple
congratulations on it but before you go
i want you to fill in the blank okay all
i want for christmas
is my album the sale there we go
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews
click subscribe or watch these videos